detective i think you stole my mojo
mojo mojo mojo
okay so lucifer is back for its fifth
season and throughout this video we're
going to be discussing the devil you
know better
than the song better the devil you know
by kylie minogue i'll skip the rubbish
puns from here on out and get straight
into the breakdown
but obviously there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to check it out yet then i highly
recommend that you check out now
as always don't forget to subscribe to
the channel for videos like this every
day
and please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy
it without the way
this is the heavy spoiler show i'm your
host definition
now let's get into our lucifer breakdown
okay so season four ended with lucifer
professing his love to chloe
and abandoning the mortal world in order
to go and reign over his kingdom in hell
season 5 deals with the fallout of that
and the repercussions of lucifer's
actions
now due to the pandemic season 5 has
been broken up into two parts
so a lot of things are left up in the
air by the end of it but we'll be giving
our theories on where things could be
going
and also the mysterious character that
could be controlling it all from behind
the scenes
now in the introduction we join lucifer
collecting the souls of the damned
torturing them in hell and slowly
turning to his more devilish side
because of the way that time works in
hell lucifer has experienced thousands
of years
going through this routine over and over
again and it's turned him into a shell
of his former self
being stuck in these loops it's almost a
loop for him
and just as his victims hate the
eternity that they're subjected to
lucifer feels very much the same way
being trapped in hell
is hell for lucifer and after realizing
that one murder victim is actually
living in their own personal nightmare
version of la
he decides to investigate their death
and this of course makes him pull up
memories of his long lost love chloe
it's a great way to start the season and
i love how the victim had
regrets over not seeing his family when
he was alive even though he had several
opportunities too
this was very relatable to me and i'm
sure most of us have a family member or
friend that
we've become strange too and though we
could easily talk to them once more
we come up with excuses not to basically
but
basically it's like that old guy in home
alone who who won't talk
to his son i'm not crying you're crying
now it too ties into the overall arc of
the season
and by the end of it we see the very
estranged family of heaven
back in each other's company once more
on the flip side of this
chloe feels completely abandoned and has
been doing whatever she can
to fill the void left by lucy i hate
calling him that
initially it appears that lucifer has
returned to her but it's revealed that
this is just his identical twin brother
michael
cue a hilarious sharon osbourne scene a
thank you for all that he did for aussie
and slowly he starts to fill a role in
her life that lucifer left behind
we learn that michael has gained the
position of god's right hand
and in doing so cut off all of the other
angels from their father's side
this pulls lucifer back to the surface
as he tries to win round chloe
and put an end to michael's schemes now
chloe discovers that she was actually
made for lucifer as a gift from god
to be his play thing on earth it's a
huge revelation for her
and she really struggles with knowing it
it also really makes us question whether
lucifer's love for her is actually real
and vice versa mirroring this we learn
that michael has been manipulating
lucifer with subliminal suggestions
that have warped the character's
decisions since the dawn of time
this is why he's made certain choices
and lucifer ends up feeling pretty
powerless
but this stems from his own personal
view of
basically how he sees himself we learn
that the character
believes he's unworthy to rule over hell
and have the power that he does
so what it boils down to is that the two
characters are actually opposite sides
of the same coin
though they're identical to look at the
ideologies that the pair possess
juxtapose one another perfectly michael
is an archangel that lorded over an army
and with this came almost unlimited
power he and lucifer battled one another
and lucifer ended up in hell seemingly
losing it all
however lucifer and michael actually
seek different things in order to
fulfill their existence
michael just wants control order and to
rule other people
on the flip side lucifer has love
friends and family
and though he lacks the power he's
actually won from what he's gained by
having a life and those around him that
care about him
now what i love about this season is
that it's not scared to take sidesteps
into the greater law and mythology
episode 4 is a great example of this and
in the 1946
film noir spectacle were introduced to a
big character in lucifer mythology
that is lilith it's someone that's been
teased time and time before
and in case you didn't know lilith is
the mother of all demons
in the hebrew bible lilith is referred
to as the first woman
and according to the text she was made
from the same clay as adam
and became his first wife however she
also refers to an earlier class of
female demon
which is how the character appears here
she's often used in fiction featuring
the devil
and you may have seen lilith as one of
the anti-heroes in chilling adventures
of sabrina
lucifer goes looking for a magic ring
and she ends up giving it to him
so that he can become mortal she
abandons her children
and retreats to a life of normality and
is rumored to die
but this is all still up in the air at
the end now it is elements like this
that add a wealth of information to the
characters
and it really helps to fill in some of
the blanks that we've had about all
their history
it's also absolutely hilarious now maze
tracks down lilith
and through this story we learned that
lender abandoned her own child when she
was younger
thematically the show is of course built
on this and
just in the same way that she left her
child lilith left hers and so on
god can also be seen as abandoning
lucifer to the underworld
which of course helped to warp his
personality if we don't know our parents
intentions
then it is possible that we won't know
our true identity
and this too mirrors chloe's journey as
she deals with the inner
turmoil over being created purely for
lucifer these elements of subtext
are truly what the season feels built
upon and it all comes together as we
head into the finale
now michael as he's done in the past
slowly starts to manipulate those around
lucifer and at one point he calls dan to
make him go to amenities house
through the window he sees lucifer's
true face and this exposes the character
to him
dan goes to charlotte's grave terrified
over what he's learned
and it's probably the most vulnerable
that we've ever seen the character
clearly he's still grieving for
charlotte and
it leads to him being easily manipulated
michael comes to him in the form of an
angel
and slowly sinks his claws into him as
he turns the character against the
protagonist
dan arrives at lucifer's home and ends
up shooting him
but this proves to have no real effect
he's gained his invulnerability back
because he's put walls up around chloe
and it's possible that after she took
his mojo for a bit
he subconsciously put things in place
this ties into the ending
and lucifer becoming invincible is one
of chloe's greatest fears
as she knows what it really means to
make matters worse
chloe is kidnapped by michael and the
season really ramps up as we head into
the final episode
we learned that michael has been
manipulating and controlling the whisper
killer
and ella discovers that it's actually
her boyfriend peter
also i love how you can see how dark
ella's mind state is becoming by the
fact that her t-shirts are
constantly getting darker throughout the
show i i know it's that
now this distrust of someone that she
loves of course mirrors chloe
who is slowly starting to lose faith in
lucifer because of the seeds of doubt
that michael sews in her mind
through the help of dan lucifer manages
to find her but that doesn't mean that
things are over
she decides to break things off with him
and slowly michael begins to tell
lucifer's life apart
just as he's about to tell her that he
loves her time freezes for the character
and he finds him in a deal at the heart
of it michael has used the fear of
learning that his son charlie is mortal
to his advantage
and it makes our men a deal unable to
break them free from the time freeze
michael arrives and mocks lucifer and it
is possible that he implanted
charlie with a cold to make him seem
mortal in order to further fuel his
father's fears
i love how both lucifer and michael also
appear as a devil and angel on his
shoulder
and this finally makes him snap he goes
to attack michael
but mazzaquin arrives in order to fend
for him
it's revealed that michael promised her
a soul in exchange for her working with
him
and the season ends with mays and the
protagonists going head-to-head for all
the things that lucy hit from her
whilst omena deal tackles michael the
battle is only ended by the intervention
of god
who steps forward for the first time in
the show played by dennis haysbert
this is the debut for the almighty and
though it ends on a big cliffhanger
there are several things that we can
take from it
obviously i think that god's
intervention has shown that he no longer
trusts michael
throughout the season we had lip service
paid to michael pretty much commanding
the army of heaven
and his father having to step forward
likely shows that he's displeased with
him
actually don't think that michael has
that long left and the way i can see him
going down has actually been hindered at
several times
throughout the series we've been told
that the archangel blades are actually
able to kill lucifer
but i think they will be used against
michael and this will end his life
episode 9 of the season is called family
dinner and clearly this hints towards
the direction that the second part will
be going
part 1 was about finding one's family
after losing it and i think that the
following episodes will center around
the rejoining of the families in the
series
and culminate in them falling apart this
will be mirrored in linda and her lost
child
god and his sons and yeah there's a lot
of things in place here
now one big thing that's also up in the
air is the fate of mazakin
clearly all she wants is a soul and i
can actually see god giving her this
but it will come at a price mazakin has
pretty much turned against all that
cared for her
and it is possible that she will become
a villain
there's also the question of eve who's
been notably absent this season
i do believe that she will return and
perhaps join sides with maize in the
second part
her first appearance very much brought
with her the idea that
it was actually her who tempted the
devil and not the other way around as
was in genesis
i have a theory and bear in mind it's a
theory but if we're keeping in with the
style of the show
i think it makes a lot of sense so i
think it could be possible that eve has
actually been controlling things behind
the scenes
and just in the same way that the fourth
season flipped her and the devil's role
it could be that she's orchestrated this
entire scenario for one specific reason
that is to pull god out of heaven in
making his family fight one another
this would force him to vacate the
kingdom similar to how she was made to
vacate the garden of eden
i would love to see it turn out that her
end game this entire time was to get all
of the angels to vacate their spots
and this would explain why she
manipulated michael into making lucifer
leave hell
which in turn would make god leave
heaven every kingdom is now hers for the
taking
and she could potentially be using maize
as a way to bring this about
the creative team are hinting at some
romance between both eve and mace
and the pair may turn out to be the big
bad for the second part
anyway that's my theory now and i'm not
even sure if lieutenant diablo or
stripper detective
could get to the bottom of it i'd of
course love to hear your thoughts on the
season though so make sure you comment
below and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up and make sure you check
out our breakdown of last week's big
netflix release project power
we're also giving away a free copy of
the avengers on any console of your
choice
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel
and drop a comment below the win is
going to be chosen at random on the 30th
of august so make sure you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button
and you can come chat to us on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy swirls on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you've been the best i've been
definition and i'll see you next time
take care peace
you